[Música]
boa noite boa tarde não sei que o
momento já estamos
primeiro ajudou muito nervoso está aqui
tipo sempre foi um sonho poder estar
aqui atrás na frente dessas três
letrinhas e e eu achei que fosse um
pouquinho mais fácil aqui hoje mas
depois de executado noves 10 spitz
nesta opção antes de mim complica ainda
mais assim o altíssimo nível então só
aumenta ainda mais o nervosismo e foi um
pouquinho com essa pergunta que eu
comecei esse meu minha fala
os meninos me convidaram pra varzim
gostaria que você falasse que me
perguntei por que eu porque eu tenho que
estar aqui nenhum de vocês eu não
inventei um produto revolucionário não
tenho uma história extraordinária não
tem nenhum tenho nada de superação da
minha trajetória
eu acredito que eu consigo compartilhar
com você
foi a minha jornada quais foram os
aprendizados e nos erros ao longo da
minha vida eu acho que eu posso chegar
um pouquinho pra vocês como eu fiz isso
eu fiz através de um jogo
o jogo chamado matrix relaxar ele é bem
fácil de jogar onde você tem que passar
pelas etapas de tal forma que você
como jogador você cria qualquer sua
missão e depois você fala com o seu
aprendizado
as quatro regras básicas para a gente
está jogando a primeira você definir
qual é seu objetivo
o que você qual é sua missão ao longo do
jogo
segundo momento de definir quem é o
personagem com quem você está jogando
normalmente é aquela pessoa que você se
inspira que você gosta você se orgulha
de estar jogando
o terceiro momento não tinha falado a
escolha da missão o momento que você
acaba uma etapa
você tem que escolher qual é a próxima
sempre visando qual é o seu objetivo do
jogo ea última é compartilhar o
aprendizado nesse momento que nos faz
refletir sobre tudo que a gente viveu e
nos preparar ainda mais para as próximas
etapas
eu escolhi o personagem senhor vê não se
combina mais de um dia voltar a jogar
normalmente cada pessoa escolhe um mapa
esse mapa tem muito a ver com aquela
história com a história que a pessoa
quer criar o mapa do pedro ao longo do
aluno na minha fala diz não perceber que
faz muito sentido pra mim cada pessoa
cria seu próprio mapa cria sua própria
jornada
acho que falei muito de regra fala muito
de como se joga talvez esteja na hora de
começar realmente jogar a minha primeira
missão é definir qual é o meu objetivo
onde eu quero chegar com esse jogo e eu
descobri isso quando tinha 11 anos uma
viagem com a minha família estava numa
paisagem linda maravilhosa eu olho para
o lado e vejo todo mundo aproveitando eu
vejo um pega o telefone e responder em
meio à frustração que eu tive naquele
momento de ver aquela minha referência é
aquela pessoa que tinha total autonomia
na decisão não podendo curtir umas
férias porque tinha que responder o
chefe raciocínio lógico ele não curte as
férias porque tinha que responder ao
chefe
portanto eu quero ser o chefe para
curtir minhas férias meu objetivo é me
prove empresa mal eu sabia naquela época
que teve a própria empresa pode fazer
trabalhar muito mais do que um
funcionário mas esse é um objetivo que
eu aprendi nessa etapa da minha vida
observa entorno
normalmente ele vai te dar muito mais
insights muito mais idéias do que você
acredita
só tem que parar de observar o que está
ao seu redor
define que quer ter uma empresa para ser
dono de uma empresa é preciso ter
responsabilidade
como que eu vou aprender a ter
essa é a próxima missão eu consegui
aprender isso quando nos 14 15 anos não
lembro muito bem
eu estava a ponto de tomar o primeiro
pau o ensino médio
repetir de ano meu pai me chamou pra
conversar já sabe que as nossas notas
não estavam boas
mas se fossem pedro se vai repetir de
ano e eu fracassei como jovem de 15 anos
eu tinha um objetivo na minha vida
naquele momento que era passar de ano
não tinha que trabalhar não tinha que
fazer nada tinha que estudar e eu não
estava conseguindo fazer aquilo naquele
momento eu percebi o que é ter
responsabilidade porque onde eu ia ser a
única pessoa que é pagar por aquele meu
erro
irmã meus pais nos amigos todo mundo
continua a vida normal rotina que segue
e eu estava ali e repetiram mais um ano
- todo mundo crescendo
naquele momento eu comecei a entender um
pouquinho mais talvez o que é ser adulto
assumir as próprias responsabilidades
isso hoje não há muita consciência de
quando assumir alguma coisa porque eu
sou responsável então eu entendo muito
mais rico riscos ao mesmo tempo eu o
valorizo muito mais aqueles momentos que
dão certo porque entende exatamente o
que eu estava assumindo a
responsabilidade ela se resume no valor
da decisão que nós tomamos porque assim
você entende realmente o que você está
assumindo
por isso o meu aprendizado nessa etapa
foi responsabilidade de fazer crescer
saibam assumir saibam falar não para
algumas responsabilidades porque elas
podem ter um peso muito bom às vezes não
entende
agora eu entendi sobre qual é o objetivo
que é a responsabilidade
deixa eu pensar como é que as empresas
daqui a cinco da cadeia daqui a 20 anos
que há 20 anos quando o bilionário poder
comprar um iate tem que trabalhar só
ficar viajando
aí eu chamei essa etapa de síndrome do
herói eu aprendi isso de uma forma muito
rápida e dura nos 17 anos yanne uma
semana
minha mãe estava perfeita trabalhando
fazendo sua rotina
e no final daquela semana ela estava à
beira da morte foi diagnosticada com uma
doença rara começou um tratamento eo
tratamento não sabendo da forma como nós
esperávamos em uma semana você todos os
planos que você tinha pra pagar 20 a 30
anos
desaparecerem por que você não sabe que
se você vai voltar no dia seguinte o
hospital investiu mãe estava viva e se
pergunta se pensar bastante sobre essa
visão de longo prazo
esse buraco que estava dentro de mim não
estava sendo preenchido mas com a
ambição um conteúdo que eu queria
e essa noção de tempo pra mim de um
saber o que fazer daqui a 10 20 e 30
anos não sabia que ia fazer daquela dois
dias não sabe o que fazer aqui há 22
meses
então hoje meu espaço temporário é muito
curto
eu até queria fazer uma pergunta pra
vocês não precisam responder mas pensa
em como é a vida de vocês nós dois anos
atrás
se hoje um pouquinho parecido com o que
vocês pensavam que era conquistar até
mesmo pensa em como era seis meses atrás
com que é hoje a velocidade com que as
coisas mudam um é muito intensa
a gente gasta energia tem um
planejamento pensando ah não vou fazer
isso não fazer aquilo porque lá na
frente pode dar tal problema a gente não
preocupa com problemas
preocupei com decisões do presente é
isso que realmente vai fazer a diferença
no seu dia a dia
e essa etapa balançou muito comigo eu
achei que fosse um super-herói que eu
não sentisse que não fosse morrer que
você é imortal que eu podia fazer tudo
não errava na verdade eu descobri que eu
sou um ser humano que um dia eu vou
morrer e que eu preciso olhar cada vez
mais está dentro então preciso saber
quem que é o pedro 5 quem é essa pessoa
eu fiz intercâmbio durante um ano
morei fora do país eu tive essa
oportunidade eu morei sozinho enquanto
estava sozinho no começo é lindo
assistir filmes que nunca que eu queria
muito assistir de séries lie bastante
a correr comecei a fazer várias
atividades mas depois de um certo tempo
estava eu percebi que estava preenchido
o meu ator estava forçando fazer alguma
coisa que eu às vezes não queria mais
econômica entende que esse preencher o
ator era medo de olhar pra dentro era
medo de dizer que quer o pedro falei
calma lá eu estou no momento que eu
posso repetir eu posso olhar eu tenho
muito tempo pra isso por que não fazer
isso
foi quando comecei a olhar muito para
dentro começou a impressionar muitas
coisas e foi até uma das coisas que
realmente não falou neste momento de
olhar pra dentro e perceber que existe
um pedro profissional eo pedro pessoal
pedro pedro que o peru é profissional
queria crescer emissão de 200
funcionários faz milhões de coisas no
peru queria viajar curtir os amigos
aprender a cozinhar
lê mais livros eu falei eu tenho dois
períodos na minha vida eu não quero
viver com o bebê como popularidade por
ser uma pessoa só que meu trabalho
esteja 100% alinhados com o pedro
no segundo momento eu tive um insight
nesse mesmo momento de reflexão e de
quem é o pedro eu percebi que nós temos
ciclos nossas vidas
eu tinha planejado boa parte do que eu
queria fazer na minha vida até aquele
intercâmbio
eu cheguei lá conquistei uma coisa que
eu queria muito foi meio que chega no
final do arco íris em um pote de ouro
agora que eu faço com o ouro era um
momento que eu tava dele em diante o que
eu vou fazer da minha vida quando eu
voltar pro brasil
e mais depois de ter pensado muito em
que esse pedro que esse pedro que é uma
coisa que vem acontecendo comigo nesse
processo eu pensei um pouquinho com que
esse é o objetivo dele diante meu
aprendizado nessa etapa é conhecida ti
mesmo
você é a pessoa que mais tem que
conhecer tantos lados positivos quanto
negativos sabe o que tem que trabalhar e
suas potencialidades
assim você vai ter certeza cada passo
que você está dando agora que me conheço
pelo menos eu me conheço um pouco mais
eu preciso começar a tomar decisões da
minha vida eu falei vou voltar pro
brasil que eu vou fazer agora escolher
onde quer trabalhar
parece um pouco ambicioso mas eu comecei
a me envolver um pouco empresa
turismo quando voltei do brasil e de
cara já me abrir o olho o emprego que eu
queria muito que eu falei é lá que eu
quero no momento em que eu falei que ia
lá que eu quero eu percebi que para
escolher alguma coisa eu abro mão de uma
série de outras decisões que eu não
estou escolhendo uma série de outras
oportunidades que poderiam surgir na
minha vida que eu estou falando não mas
naquele momento eu estava muito
consciente
eu não quero tudo aquilo eu quero esse
emprego
eu queria ele de forma tão obstinada que
estava disposto a abrir mão do meu
salário para alguns meses para estar lá
eu acreditava muito que aquilo e ajuda
na minha vida e ajuda a atingir o
objetivo é conseguir passar no emprego
eles realmente eh eh deu certo eu não
tinha que abrir mão do salário mas
história de todo momento sabendo o que
eu pude estar abrindo mão me fez cada
vez se entender mais esse processo eu
estar presente por isso toda escolha
normalmente os sacrifícios são
necessários ao longo dessa jornada
eu fui aproveitando muitas oportunidades
eu fui vivendo vários momentos que a
vida me apresenta no momento que estou
hoje é um momento de entender ou criar
as minhas oportunidades
trabalhei algumas empresas trabalham
alguns projetos e agora cadê o projeto
do pedro
cabe à empresa que o pedro tanto fala
esse objetivo de vida dele agora que ele
vai abrir falar a verdade pra vocês uma
sensação que dá muito medo quando você
tem alguém que respalda as suas decisões
você fica muito mais tranqüilo nasceu
errado alguém que me ajuda se alguma
coisa acontecer ele vai corrigir mas
quando é você colocar a cara a tapa é
você que vai corrigir o erro dos outros
é o seu nome está lá embaixo a parada é
diferente de quando em quando para as
pessoas que se acham lindo nossa que
legal que irado com que seu projeto
sexto conta de energia que vai fazer
coisas
o milionário não sei como assim
não sei o que vou fazer está tudo bem
não preciso ter certeza que vai ser o
próximo passo
eu sei qual é o objetivo onde eu quero
chegar e essa máscara essa pressão que a
gente precisa saber tudo ser friamente
calculado ou pelo menos fingir que
sabemos tudo é não precisa existir
porque sei que as oportunidades nem
sempre elas vão aparecer exatamente
quando você quer
às vezes elas surgem em algum momento
que você espera finalmente elas surgem
quando está buscando alguma coisa quando
você busca aquela oportunidade faz muito
sentido para você eu tenho nesse momento
eu quero muito criar tanto aberto mas
que eu vou fazer agora não sei que está
tudo bem
não foi isso que eu aprendi essa leveza
nesse processo não ter essa pressão tão
grande de tudo eu te falei vários
aprendizados para vocês hoje à noite
várias coisas mas se eu quisesse que
vocês aí sim com uma essência um
aprendizado forte seja essas três
palavras aqui observar decisão e com
isso porque no momento que você olha pra
fora
você entende o que está acontecendo no
seu ambiente em que as pessoas estão
falando o que o seu ambiente de trabalho
tudo que está acontecendo no seu dia a
dia
depois se olha para dentro você sente
que aquele ambiente te falando eu estou
bem nesse lugar me faz bem estar aqui
uma vez que você entende completou
alcança sua reação precisa exterior
você consegue tomar uma decisão muito
mais consciente se você estar presente
você entende o porquê da sua decisão
depois que isso acontece você mais uma
vez olha o ambiente não ver como é a
reação das suas decisões e mais uma vez
se você olha para dentro tomar decisões
e tudo mais um ciclo acontece várias e
várias vezes
não sei se vocês perceberam mas eu falei
que eu mudei meu objetivo
isso acontece porque toda vez que você
entra um ciclo você está diferente
na cozinha como é que eu faço isso
porque o senhor km de ficar fazendo
todos os dias olha analisa toda uma
visão olha pra toda a minha eu faço isso
não
normalmente quando eu sinto que eu tenho
algum desconforto naquele ambiente
quando se tem alguma coisa que está me
incomodando no peito não sei o que é mas
normalmente quando comecei a pensar nas
atividades fora quando começar a pensar
em outras coisas não naquilo que estou
fazendo é sinal de que talvez eu tenha
que mudar neste momento é quando eu vou
pro mata no egito mais me deixando muito
mais e eu queria muito falar pra vocês
que isso é a solução eu saio de cada um
desses momentos meus de encerramento de
ciclo eo lá achei a solução da minha
vida
na verdade eu saí com muito mais o que
eu não quero fazer da minha vida o que
eu quero eu te falo isso já ajuda muito
na tomada de decisão não quero me
envolver com isso isso isso quero estar
ali
isso varia muito esse processo eu falei
que toda vez que você entra nisso você
repense há muito quem você é e é natural
o seu objetivo mude tanto é que meu
objetivo ao longo da minha jornada mudou
logo que voltei de intercâmbio percebi
eu não quero ter minha própria empresa
eu não faço questão de ter funcionários
ter uma marca forte de ser alguém
poderoso do que o seu próprio chef uma
diferença é sutil mas eu quero condenar
nos próprios projetos aquilo que eu
quero é que às vezes são pressionados
comigo e não como a marca uma coisa
definida não tem certo e errado tem
definições
esse processo de escolha de entender o
objetivo que talvez muito que você
sempre está num ciclo se você sempre
está mudando talvez você nunca chega no
seu objetivo de vida
está tudo bem porque cada vez você está
mais próximo dele também
porém cada vez um objetivo novo objetivo
da sua vida que você começa a entender
que seu objetivo de vida
você nunca vai alcançar porque não é de
começar a olhar para a sexta jornada que
está vivendo
olhar para cada decisão nós estamos
tomando
o principal sentido contrário nossa
jornada e talvez eu volte àquela
pergunta eu comecei porque eu porque eu
acredito que estou presente em todas as
decisões estão presentes na construção
dessa minha jornada
se fosse eu vou conseguir uma empresa se
você meu próprio chefe
eu tenho certeza ainda está tudo bem mas
aproveitar cada oportunidade eu entendo
cada fechamento de ciclo e esse momento
eu tenho certeza que qualquer pessoa
simples podem ser extraordinárias
terminei a minha fala perguntando vocês
já pararam pra ser extraordinários hoje
muito obrigada e boa noite
[Aplausos]